hello everyone and yes Magnus Carlsen
has released a statement regarding the
last few weeks so before we do anything
else and there is a a nice game that we
are going to check out let's check out
this statement Magnus posted yesterday
on Twitter uh so here it is the Magnus
Carlson himself saying my statement
regarding the last few weeks and then he
used the uh an image to to upload those
letters as uh it would be too many
characters for Twitter so here dear
Chess World at the 2022 singfield cup I
made an unprecedented professional
decision to withdraw from the tournament
after my round three game against Hans
Niemann a week later during the
Champions chest where I resigned against
Hans Neiman after playing only one move
so yeah that obviously you guys know as
this chess drama has uh has you know uh
uh gotten absolutely everywhere and
there's just no no hiding even if you're
not interested in just whatsoever you
have heard about this so I know that my
actions have frustrated many in the
chess Community I'm frustrated I want to
play just I want to continue to play
Chess at the highest level in the best
events I believe that cheating in chess
is a big deal and an existential threat
to the game I also believe that chess
organizers and all those who care about
the sanctity of the game we love I
should seriously consider increasing
security measures and the methods of
cheap detection for over the board chess
when Neiman was invited last minute to
the 2022 singfield cup I strongly
considered withdrawing from the uh
withdrawing prior to the event I
ultimately chose the play something that
you might have also heard that when
janiponishi heard that Hans Niemann was
will be a substitute for the hard
Rapport who was who who was supposed to
be playing in the single cup he
contacted the organizers and said that
they should increase security due to
Hans playing as uh well no obviously
nepo knew something that the rest of us
were not aware of and then he says I
believe that Neiman has cheated more and
more recently than he has publicly
admitted his over the board progress has
has been unusual and throughout our game
in the single cup I had the impression
that he wasn't a tense or even fully
concentrating on the game in critical
positions while outplaying me as black
in a way I think only a handful of
players can do this game contributed to
changing my perspective now that's
something that's um okay you really have
to trust the magnus's opinion on this
one because I mean how would we react if
someone is someone really really strong
just comes along and starts destroying
everyone like Magnus did when he came
and you know just started trashing
people around when Bobby Fischer came
when you know any uh greatest chess
player who ever lived you know if now in
the mother in the era of modern engines
how are we to say if he's actually good
or obviously he's using external
assistance as no one can defeat the a
world champion like that and especially
like Magnus says here not uh not be
interested in the game where there's a
lot to calculate and where the position
is really intense I believe of course
anything is possible but yeah I mean
Magnus does have the experience he he
would know but again that's that that's
no evidence uh we must do something
about cheating and for my part going
forward I don't want to play against
people that have cheated repeatedly in
the past because I don't know what they
are capable of doing in the future so
Magnus here is saying that although they
do not have any evidence regarding the
Scandal that occurred in Saint Louis uh
none of this was um going to be about
that obviously everyone was thinking
like there's going to be some sort of a
Smoking Gun but uh yeah obviously it's a
tailored towards uh uh Hans being maybe
invited to future events or you know
other people boycotting playing against
hunts or or you know something in that
direction as of course I I doubt that we
will ever know uh what actually happened
in that game uh that that Magnus Lost In
classical chess so there is more that I
would like to say unfortunately at this
time I'm limited in what I can say
without explicit permission from Neiman
to speak openly so far I have only been
able to speak with my actions and those
actions have stated clearly that I'm not
willing to play chess with Neiman I hope
that the truth of this matter comes out
uh or whatever it may be sincerely
Magnus Carlsen World chess champion so
uh that's something that I believe that
will continue if um and like like I said
on Twitter uh if uh or if an organizer
has an opportunity to invite Magnuson to
invite Neiman and Magnus says all right
I'm not going to play if you invite
Neiman then unfortunately I believe that
Neiman will not be invited simply
because uh the tournament organizer
wants the most coverage that they can
get and and I mean having magnets in the
tournament will yield the most coverage
so if that will be the case it will be
very hard to uh for Neiman to get into
Invitational tournaments and the
invitationals are the absolute uh the
top level tournaments where you can gain
the most below where all the elites are
playing so that's the the statement
Magnus gave regarding his last few weeks
not a lot about the event that everyone
was actually interested in and that
everyone was fuming about
um was there any actual cheating
involved in the uh in the classical game
that Magnus lost but rather I believe
that it's um well the actions and
everything is mostly tailored to how
everyone will treat hunts in in future
events and I'm very interested to see
how hunts will deal with this as uh I
mean the the there's just no no good way
of dealing with this if uh imagine if he
didn't do anything wrong if he's just
that strong then okay everyone's just uh
you know unjustly accusing him and even
though it's okay you could say okay this
is suspicious we have this evidence we
have this evidence we have this evidence
none of that is actually evidence if any
of that was evidence then we would not
be having any discussion so it that
cannot be considered evidence but yeah
it will be it will be very interesting
I'm as usual of course very interested
to hear what you guys think and you know
what would you do because everyone in
this you know in situations like these
everyone will act according to their
past experiences and basically that has
uh nothing to do with with the actual
situation here it's just you know how
you view the world and how you uh think
the the world around you should should
revolve but um yeah I mean uh this is
the internet we are here for for the
opinions and everyone has an opinion uh
so yeah uh that's the info regarding the
Magnus uh tweaked uh hope you guys
enjoyed that and now I would like to
show you one game and I try to uh you
know I tried to make it as fast game as
possible so this is a Blitz game from
the Lindora sabital Memorial last year
where Neiman has the black pieces
against a very strong Russian
Grandmaster Pavel ponkratov uh who was I
believe rated some 2650 at the time so
very very strong Russian Grandmaster
uh and uh let's just see how the game
went as it features a very cool opening
the the Great Snake opening so here we
have C4 Pavel opens with the English
opening with G6 Knight to C3 and now
Bishop to G7 at the Great Snake
variation we have H for now immediately
going after that uh G6 pawn and now uh
there is one game in the database where
H6 was played but here Hans plays Knight
to F6 and now already as of move three
uh we have a completely new gain so E4
we have E5 with Bishop to E2 and now
Pawn to H5 so a very very weird setup
here Knight to F3 Knight to C6 and now
Pawn to D4 and okay just striking in the
center nothing odd here e captures and
now Knight captures on D4 okay hunt says
I will grab that pawn so Knight captures
an E4 Knight captures an E4 and now
Bishop captures on D4 we have Bishop to
G5 attacking hans's Queen uh Ponta F6
only move and now Bishop the F4 and here
we have Pawn to D6 by Hans we have
castles castles and now Bishop to D3
putting pressure on that G6 Pawn so of
course Hans immediately reacts to this
and now you could consider a lot of
moves here like maybe the safest option
would be some like Knight G3 you attack
the bishop force a trade of Bishops and
once the queen attacks the G6 Pawn you
play King G7 and then white plays
whatever and the game continues with
black maybe being slightly better but in
the game Pavel decided as this was a
Blitz game you have to play very fast he
decided to play Knight captures on D6
and the idea is clear he wants the
capture on F5 and then bust open the
position with uh Queen captures on H5
and there are ways to deal with this
Hans plays C characters on V6 even
though there is the very clear
refutation of just playing Bishop
captures Queen captures and now King G7
and the Knight is trapped the Knight
cannot move if you move the Knight of
course there's the queen queen action
here and then let's say you move the
Knight F5 knight move just Bishop
captures I have to check and the queen
will pick up the queen so instead Hans
decides to play C captures on D6 and
okay now Bishop captures on F5 uh Pavel
gets what he wanted G captures Queen
captures on H5 and now Hans has to
defend this uh and it's not easy to
attack you would have to first get a
rook in the game if you can play
something like Rogue D1 Rook D3 Rook G3
you are probably winning or if the
bishop moves then you play some like F4
maybe Rook F3 Rook to G3 uh of course
you you would be very happy but that's a
lot of moves Hans plays Queen to D7 we
have Rook a to D1 preparing the plan and
now Bishop to E5 offering a trade with
Bishops and now Pavel plays Bishop to H6
and this is uh again not the most
precise way to play is now Hans just
plays Queen to H7 uh he uh traps the
bishop and of course if the bishop moves
then the queen is trapped and a bishop
therefore is coming so you will not be
able to save this bishop so what can you
play here of course you could play
something like G3 to stop Bishop F4 but
then King h8 The Rook is coming to G8 so
after King H2 let's say Rook the G8 F4
uh what do you play here it would be a
fun position but after Bishop D4 white
uh White really does not have a a move
here it's not gonna help him Rook G6 is
coming and then the bishop will fall
either way so instead after Queen H7 B4
was played uh here uh Pavel finds a very
nice move and I mean of course you have
to look at B4 when when you're looking
for a nice move uh B5 is the threat and
now if the the Knight can be dislodged
from C6 then you will get access to this
D4 Square because he really wants to
play F4 and now a bishop D4 check will
be deadly as the Knight covers the D4
Square so he wants to get rid of the
knight's control over the D4 Square G
sorry after V4 we have Bishop to F4
going after uh the the bishop Here and
Now point to B5 but now Knight the E5
and Rook captain address and D6 there's
no more way of saving the bishop Queen
captures an H6 with Queen captures on F5
and now uh Hans is of material and uh
well his King is wide in the open but he
finds a very very clean win he just
plays Knight to F3 with check and he was
in this position unmove 22 that Pavel
Punk retro resigned in the game as there
is nothing more to be done here my point
is that if the Knight is accepted then
just a king to each it and there's no
defense against Rook to G8 also the The
Rook is still still hanging you have no
time to deal with all of this you have
to make some room for your king but then
you just go on a nice King had room G8
King Turf one Bishop captures and E6
let's say Rook captures Queen to C1 with
check King E2 Queen capture C for check
and if Queen D3 now the Rooks come into
play Rook day 8 check of course King D2
Queen before check and whatever you play
a nice Rook to see it checking the one
and now Rook to G1 and you get the
checkmate at King T2 and now Rook or
queen to E1 will be Checkmate and on the
other hand after an i2f3 check if you
don't accept the Knight if you play King
to H1 doesn't really matter just Queen
page for check Queen to H3 and now Queen
captures spawn captures and only now you
pick up the rook and now you are up a
full night bishop and Rook so of course
completely winning
uh so yeah very nice game with black by
Hans against the 2650 Grand Master in
the tall Memorial of 2021 uh I believe
the tournament Was Won by Marty Ross and
in the end Niemann and ended up in 10th
place so it was a it was a good result
but not maybe the the best as as you
know everyone is expecting in England to
just Crush everyone nowadays but yeah
that's the game hope you guys enjoyed it
and the uh the Public Announcement
Magnus made regarding the last few weeks
it's not what the Chess World was was
hoping for or even expecting but it is
it is what it is so what do you make of
it do share in the comments I'm very
very interested in reading them as usual
uh so yeah that's the game and the
statement hope you guys enjoyed that I
would like to thank Andrew man Shukla
Henry Spraggins Mr Robert de crayon
Sauron medrata and Michael ovens for a
contribution to my channel thank you a
lot I really appreciate it as usual you
can check to my previous videos here
thank you for watching and I will see
you soon continuing to check up on your
wonderful suggestions and whatever else
happens in the Chess World so thank you
all I will see you soon and have an
excellent rest of your day